there's more art
in my head
joe ordinary
than there is in
half the museums on this planet well how
then it's it's what's maddening is how
narrow the reduction valve is you know
we've been making art for 5 000 years
and what have we got we've got a few
museums full of some nice stuff but what
have we got in our heads 50 000 times
more good stuff
but very hard to get out
and really hard to get out when you're
carving it in dire right and granite and
you know
but
somehow this
barrier between us and these realms of
art you don't even have to talk
philosophy you don't have to call it
the platonic realm of ideas or or
some higher imperium you just have to
say beauty there's a great deal of
beauty on the other side of this tiny
keyhole that we're looking through and
if technology gives us a way to open the
door and all waltz through dancing
it seems to me that would be a spiritual
renaissance that what happens at a
spiritual renaissance is by some means
the collective soul
becomes collectively known
like in the italian renaissance the
invention of oil painting allowed
great geniuses to portray
the major themes moving in the
archetypal unconscious of their patrons
and the populations who viewed their
paintings and themselves
and it
it's a shared epiphany it's a spiritual
quest it's a group transformation but
it's it's driven by and led by the
revelation
of art
i hope i live to see the day i mean i
don't care i don't know about
downloading consciousness into a machine
what i
would
be able to die happy with is a
technology that could capture
just a
snapshot
or a film clip of one's thoughts
so you know you would rig up on dmt or
psilocybin or something and when you
really got into the good stuff you'd hit
the record button
and have it and then you could come back
down with it and model it and adam braid
it and move it around edit it explore
unpack certain parts
my god the power of art that could be
created that way
and and again i it's ordinary people i'm
convinced it's not
what genius is is the ability to bring
it back not the ability to encounter it
every single one of us can encounter it
and that's very telling
and almost an argument for our divinity
because here we are at the end of some
long
darwinian evolution
tree of windowing so that all we have
are what we need
and yet apparently one of the things we
need is an ocean of alien beauty
just right behind your eyebrows
seems to me
if that's something we must have in our
tool kit then
someone with greater intelligence than
us must know a lot more than we do about
the journey we're making
the ultimate result of all this
electronic technology is the
literalizing of consciousness
that consciousness is coming into being
that's why you know the 19th century had
no industry equivalent to
to hollywood
and hollywood is a huge
sector of the national economy and what
is it concerned with it it builds dreams
it pedals
images it's entirely involved in the
production of the imagination
and think of a company like ilm
industrial light and magic
they're not kidding and when you look at
their corporate ledger you understand
they're not kidding and wish you had
stock in it because industrial light and
magic is making very real money
so
uh i i think that all of these
technologies and the and the psychedelic
shamanism and the emphasis on a
vocabulary of spiritualism and direct
experience but what this is all leading
to is the greatest empowering of the
imagination
since the birth of language and that the
effects are similarly similarly
unpredictable
but the thing is
that it's happening faster than any
straight person can anticipate
you know tim leary had a wonderful
saying back in the 60s he said
find the others
find the others
well if you go on to the net
no matter what your concern is you know
the restoration of south german
harpsichords or whatever it is
there are hundreds of people waiting
to share their secrets with you to
passionately to communicate with you to
draw you into a community the net is a
tremendous permission for eccentricity
you know if you're a 245 pound white
male and you want to present yourself as
a seven-year-old black girl who's made
the great victory over polio
hey nobody can stop you from doing that
on the net on the net you are who you
say you are
and
all interest groups no matter how
peculiar and formerly insulated can
contact each other instantly
and
so the idea the very notion of orthodoxy
is melting away
uh
freakery
is the wave of the future the bohemians
knew it the pataphysicians knew it the
dados knew it the surrealists knew it
the hippies the
uh the even the zippy's
eccentricity and the empowerment of
individuality
is a paradoxical part of living
in an electronic collectivity
everything is happening right on time
right on schedule i mean this is the
thing that
if you believe knowledge is power which
i certainly do then the internet is
the
dispensation you know the angels have
landed the aliens have unfurled their
banner on this planet and uh
now let's see
if information can liberate that's why i
don't want to do something stupid like
die and miss
the whole
unfoldment of this
proposition
that
knowledge is power information
will liberate and it will be settled in
the next
10 or 15 years
either they'll get a handle on it
whoever they are whatever a handle means
or it will slip from their control and
it will be clear that
some kind of dialogue is now going on
between
individual human beings and the sum
total of human knowledge and that
nothing can stop it it's some kind of
renaissance some kind of
total
new relationship to knowledge
and possibility is put in place
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you